bonsoir à tous je vais vous citer une
série de mots et d'expressions qui se
rapportent tous aux banlieues que vous
avez l'habitude d'entendre à la radio la
télévision ou de lire dans les journaux
chômage solitude promiscuité
désoeuvrement délinquance peur colère
bavures policières émeutes urbaines
association entraide solidarité racisme
explosion sociale etc
on pourrait continuer longtemps cette
manière syncopé de dire la banlieue en
voici une autre façon par l'image et
pardon à ceux qui ont dès qu'ils ont
déjà vu ces images au journal de 20
heures mathieu kassovitz acteurs et
réalisateurs comme acteur et obtenu le
césar du meilleur jeune comédien pour
votre rôle dans le regard des hommes
tombés de jacques audiard comme
réalisateur après midi sous acide donc
votre deuxième long métrage la haine qui
sera présenté demain soir à cannes en
compétition officielle et pour tous les
festivaliers en smoking robe de soirée
ça va être un sacré choc j'ajoute que
vous n'avez que 28 ans côté de vous saïd
taghmaoui vous êtes comédiens vous êtes
l'un des trois acteurs principaux avec
hubert koundé vincent cassel
trois jeunes de donc je ne deviens la
cité trois amis dont le film raconte la
déambulation tragique jo vous êtes le
rappeur du groupe iam groupe qui avec
d'autres a écrit des musiques inspirées
par le film de kassovitz philippe taghli
poète et photographe ou publient un
album de photos d'enfants de la banlieue
l'ec raismes ligne de la cité doses aux
éditions du cherche midi d'ailleurs
derrière moi c'est l'une de vos photos
qu'on peut voir et une exposition de vos
photos à des présentes et la fnac de la
défense et à la fnac de créteil et on
pourrait bientôt voir la même exposition
ofnac de cergy pontoise et de noisy le
grand
sylvine bailly vous êtes directeur
associé du groupe image c'est vous qui
êtes l'auteur avec erik orsenna de cet
excellent documentaire nous avons pu
voir dimanche soir sur france 2 jours
ordinaires de la cité filmé dans les
quartiers nord de marseille
et puis adil jason lee vous êtes
sociologue vous êtes le fondateur et le
directeur des instituts banlieue skopies
et auteur d'une enquête publié chez plon
sous le titre une saison en banlieue et
puis alors derrière vous il y à des
jeunes justement des banlieues qui ont
vu le film de kassovitz qui pourront
s'exprimer tout à l'heure pour dire
leurs sentiments poser des questions ils
feront ce qu'ils voudront
et puis je devais recevoir aussi
monsieur jean de boishue qui est le
député-maire d'une d'une ville de la
banlieue parisienne et qui vient
d'ailleurs d'être nommé
je savais pas si j'allais vite et qu'il
est nommé dans le gouvernement d'alain
juppé secrétaire d'état à l'enseignement
supérieur et j'avais invité parce qu'il
est l'auteur d'un témoignage d'une série
de portraits sur des gens des banlieues
d'hier et d'aujourd'hui
l ouvrage que j'ai trouvé très
intéressant qui publie aux éditions de
la table ronde
mais voilà il est candidat aux élections
municipales et la campagne officielle a
commencé depuis ce matin 0 heure est
donc une liste concurrente de la sienne
déposé réclamation auprès du csa et donc
le csa m'a dit aujourd'hui qu'il était
est impossible que j'habite monsieur
jean de boishue et gedo donc j'ai dû
donc sur les injonctions du csa renoncer
à sa présence je regrette beaucoup
alors m mathieu kassovitz la haine parce
que la haine c'est un sentiment que vous
même vous connaissez vous avez connu
[Musique]
non enfin web ou oui bien sûr mais
peut-être pas dans ce contexte de films
il parle du film est ce que vous mais
vous comme ça mathieu kassovitz vous
avez 28 ans qui vous est arrivé de
ressentir ce qu'on appelle la haine
c'est à dire quelque chose qui vous
ronge l'âme qui vous ronge des autres
qui vous attaquent la moelle et ses
acquis
est ce que vous l'avez ressenti vraiment
je pense j'ai trop de respect pour les
gens qui ont vraiment des raisons
d'avoir la haine pour pouvoir dire ça
oui alors c'est la haine est un film qui
raconte 24 heures deux de trois jeunes
gens de la banlieue
mais c'est aussi à l'évidence un film
anti flic c'est pas un film anti
policiers dans le sens primaire du sujet
c'est vraiment c'est un film anti 6 le
système qui fait que la police et comme
elle est dire qu'il ya des policiers ont
des armes ils sont
et non ils n'ont pas la formation
nécessaire ils sont pas assez payés ils
travaillent dans des conditions
difficiles et malheureusement ils sont
plus en plus son jeu d'obea hérarchie à
un ordre et ça tue et l'individualité et
puis forcément ça ça amène des bavures
mais vous même vous c'est pas un fixé
par bible contre les flics parce qu'il
ya des bons flics il ya des mauvais flic
il ya toutes sortes de gens différents
donc on veut pas on peut pas englober
les choses vous même vous n'avez pas la
haine des flics bas vont se dire que
j'ai pas la haine des flics quand ils
viennent il ya les bons flics et les
bleus fric jallais maine démographique
alors bien de ce qui vous est venu
d'ailleurs d'une bavure policière
il ya une série de bavures en 93 et à
macau mais qui est qui s'est fait tirer
une balle dans la tête dans un
commissariat du 18e et puis un
enchaînement de choses qui fait que l'on
peut se poser la question comment
comment comment aujourd'hui dans ce pays
on peut se lever le matin et se prenait
une balle dans la tête le soir dans la
présentation du film là vous dit ceci je
voulais faire un film qui rentre dans
l'art ça pour entrer dans l'art il
rentre dans le lard c'est vrai mais pour
rentrer dans le lard de qui je sais pas
du sujet le sujet c'est à des problèmes
ça non pas on parle de bavure policière
il faut pas le faire de façon il faut il
faut le faire avec recul parce que c'est
pas c'est pas simple c'est pas des
histoires qui arrive il ya des gens qui
payent les qui paye les pots cassés
cirque il ya toujours des blessés
toujours les mêmes mais qui se prennent
des balles mais si jamais la faute et
est jamais que d'un côté
non mais curieusement elle serait partie
l'expression rentrer dans la requête une
expression très fort j'ai pensé que
derrière vous vouliez dire qu' il y
avait chez vous une sorte de façon de
deux peut-être de choquer les bonnes
consciences d'alerté et de prévenir non
mais oui enfin où j'avais un grand père
qui faisait ce qu'il faut c'est de
choquer le bourgeois c'est vrai que
c'est vachement c'est quelque chose de
intéressant à faire parce que c'est les
gens et qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'il faut
réveiller il faut rêver leur conscience
et si c'est possible
bon on reste qu on sait ce n'est qu'un
film donc on peut pas faire c'est pas
non plus la révolution mais c'est vrai
que si parler c'est juste des ces sujets
là c'est déjà assez difficile c'est déjà
assez délicat est ce que c'est même pas
sûr qu'on devrait qu'il est bien le
faire des films comme ça donc
appartement mon le fait il faut les il
faut l'assumer jusqu'au bout il faut le
faire d'une façon assez appuyé il faut
prendre les partis pris je ne sais pas
de demain soir à cannes au palais quand
tu vas te présenter devant tout le monde
à la robe de soirée en smoking ça va
quand même chauffé ça vous allez rentrer
dans le lard là on savait le fait d'être
à cannes ça fait que le film a été et
est rentré dans une institution je pense
pas que les gens à cannes soit choqué
parce que les chicanes et trop protégé
s'il va lancer une bombe nucléaire
au milieu de cannes tout tout tout
serait foutu sauf calme donc je crois
qu'ils vont voir ça ils vont ils vont
ils vont trouver ça très sympathique et
ils vont passer à autre chose je pense
pas que ça les choque et unique saleh
remette en question je vois pas les gens
sortir dans la rue jetté leurs smokings
et dire il c'est vrai ça suffit il faut
passer à autre chose d'un excédent
l'autre mais c'est pour ça que je pense
pas que ça choque plus que ça pourquoi
le film en noir et blanc parce que le
noir et blanc amène bon ben c'est comme
les photos comme ce travail l'image je
sais pas où tu affrontes pas de mieux
expliquer mais mais moi je l'utilisé
parce que le noir et blanc on sort donc
du réaliste puisque puisque c'est du
noir et blanc ce pas la couleur et
ramène déjà un côté plus dramatique aux
images et il fait prendre conscience aux
spectateurs qu'il est en train de
regarder quelque chose de différent qui
n'est pas réel mais qui est ancrée dans
le vert mais la colle à la couleur de la
haine de la colère c'est le rouge et le
noir ça c'est le couleurs d'anarchie
aussi oui vous n'auriez pas pu le faire
en couleurs que là aussi bien sûr non
mais la méfiance est plus fort aurait pu
être fait caméra à l'épaule il vous
pensez aussi que non utilisés
tout simplement parce que je pense que
les couleurs ne sont qu'une illusion
et puis quand on mélange le noir et le
blanc le noir et le blanc on obtient le
grec ouaki et puis voilà
la couleur de la banlieue
qu'appelez-vous le syndrome du porge
sein nombre du porche c'est c'est eh mec
qui se lève soit il y en a qui s'élève à
8 9 heures qui se lève à midi une heure
et puis qui sont en jeu here we keep
altima qui ruine qui roule enfin qu'il
traîne mais d'ailleurs dans le film
à un moment je suis plus qu'elle est toi
qui lis bon ben maintenant on fait quoi
moi c'était une sorte de leitmotiv
mais ils auront bien dans le film ce
côté un peu de ces trois jeunes qui
passent la journée à se demander ce
qu'ils vont faire
et malheureusement c'est le lot de
beaucoup de gens dans ces quartiers qui
n'ont pas de travail toujours qu'ils
n'ont pas forcément je dirais une
journée organisée selon un calendrier
bien précis
il ya un peu dans ce film je trouve de
très bons passages sur le fait qu'il
brouille qu'ils attendent des choses qui
arrivent qui n'arrive pas à le secret
des événements et puis lorsque ça arrive
parfois c'est dramatique mais il ya
toute cette lenteur de la journée qui
est qui bien rendu oui mais là il pu le
temps et finalement cet ancien militant
qui va les tuer bien sûr je l'attends
qui les tue c'est le temps qui les tue
ce qui va frapper d'ailleurs en voyant
ce film c'est que ces trois jeunes gens
où qu'ils aillent il déclenché des
polémiques il dément déclenché des cris
déclenché des bagarres et même entre eux
entre taux entre 3 vous savez si ou la
base là mon avis la journée de deux mecs
qui sont pris une balle
ou qui ont subi les bavures policières
c'est des journées les plus les plus
chiants est possible c'est les mecs et
forcément il ya une chance sur deux
bouts qui soit vraiment rien passé dans
la journée donc moi à la base j'ai voulu
faire un film comme ça je voulais qu'il
se passe rien et quand on parle d'un
nombre du porche pas ce que je fais un
court métrage vraiment la réalité est
plus évident c'est à dire qu'il se passe
vraiment rien et là on s'est rendu
compte que l'on se rend compte très vite
que 1h30 on est obligé de faire du
cinéma
on peut pas se faire chier parce que je
ne peux pas faire chier spectateurs
c'est pas ça marche pas comme ça il faut
créer des choses donc il se passe des
choses dans le film c'est un condensé de
24 heures d'une journée qui normalement
se déroule sur six mois c'est à dire
qu'on a pris les événements les plus
importants mais il faut pas oublier
qu'on fait du cinéma et que on a fait ce
film dans un sens puis enfin pas
purement mais évidemment si le mato
graphique donc on appris des partis pris
qui sont qui sont qu'on peut défendre on
peut attaquer aussi c'est à dire que on
a cassé un peu de réalisme avec on a
cassé le côté documentaire le côté
juridique en ramenant des éléments un
peu folklorique ou un peu
mais c'est vrai mathieu kassovitz est
vrai que évidemment il ya ce parti pris
de la création qui fait que vous pouvez
pas raconter une histoire sur six mois
mais c'est vrai que en ramenant tout ça
sur 24 heures on voit très bien que ces
trois jeunes gens
c'est vrai que ou qu'ils aillent il
rencontre il est même entre eux ils ne
rencontrent jamais la paix et même entre
eux mais bon ça c'est dans le film parce
qu'il ya plein de moments où il se passe
rien c'est pas la guerre tout le temps
non plus faut pas déconner mais j'ai
peur mais dans le film
là on était obligé on est obligé de
ramener un peu de fatigue pour ça que le
film et c'est pour ça qu'il faut bien
faire attention un truc ce film moi y'a
plein de films qui vont sortir sur des
sur des problèmes de banlieue et sur ce
genre de sujet nous on l'a traité d'une
certaine façon et c'est pas la bouffe
c'est pas la meilleure façon c'est pas
la moins bonne c'est une façon elles se
défendent comme voilà mai mais il ya
plein de il ya plein d'autres
possibilités de parler du sujet alors
voici une scène du film où ils sont tous
les trois donc il ya saïd le maghrébin
qui est malin sympa très amicale il ya
eu berl africain qui est plutôt
pacifiste et puis vince le juif qui lui
ne croit qu'à la haine saïd
vous avez évidemment le détroit vous
êtes le plus sympathique parce que c'est
le rusé malin
mickeal débrouillards plein d'humour
c'est vrai nom mais ça vous correspondra
vivant dans la vie oui parce que vous
dites que mathieu s'est inspiré de mois
pour écrire le personnage de sayid vous
êtes inspiré de seuils le truc c'est que
je me suis inspiré de saïd mais saïd et
pas comme ça dans la vie non c'est un
rôle c'est un comédien il a il a composé
son rôle a dit mathieu s'inspirait
entraînés ensemble depuis longtemps donc
voilà il faut automatiquement face pyrda
de l'autre quoi oui oui on travaille
ensemble et forcément comme j'ai écrit
avant les trois personnages s'appellent
saïd hubert et vincent ce qu'il
correspond au nombre des trois comédiens
c'est pas pour rien c'est parce que on a
eu des jets essayé d'utiliser et on a
essayé d'utiliser les caractéristiques
de chaque comédien pour faire pour créer
des personnages mais sanaa mais c'est la
part du travail de comédien au plur
parce que pour vous ça y est ce que ce
film a aussi une vocation de mise en
garde aussi vous voyez comme ça où
mais comme il est à l'heure ça reste
qu'un film je pense est déjà si c'est ça
une mise en garde individuel déjà c'est
pas mal après je suis passé à ce qu'un
film quoi ouais c'est pas un film qui va
faire changer quoi que ce soit je pense
donc ça correspond à une vérité parce
qu'à plusieurs vérités en banlieue et là
c'est une vérité c'est bien que ce film
existe je compte vous regrettez que ce
film ne change puisse pas changer les
choses parce qu'il faut plus qu'un film
pour faire changer les choses parce que
c'est compliqué on est on est on est lui
c'est un réalisateur chez un acteur on
n'est pas des politiciens
on peut juste retranscrire une certaine
réalité de la vie à travers du cinéma
vous pensez pas qu une oeuvre d'art peut
avoir aussi un impact formidable assez
conscience indirectement sur peut
révéler des faits révélés ddd certaine
conscience certes un certain problème
mais peu comme ce que je disais
gr jamais de réaction directe et sail
away est-ce que vous avez nourri ce film
de votre expérience de la banlieue bien
sûr c'est évident comment ben moi je
suis né en banlieue j'ai grandi en
banlieue qu'automatiquement j'ai nourri
au langage dans la manière et dans tout
dans tout la façon de s'exprimer la
façon de marcher à la façon de regarder
la façon de penser la façon de vivre
tout simplement et sera inspiré de la
vie personnelle aura bien sûr c'est
tellement larges sanctions c'est
tellement de large et tous les
personnages qui existent avec said on
attend il y avait des gens qu'on connaît
qui sont comme dans le film et lui il a
des exemples j'ai des exemples aussi on
en a parlé on a mis en confrontation et
il n'y a pas d'unité dans les cités crc
pas c'est pas tous les gens sont pas
comme ça ou comme autrement c'est chacun
fonctionne d'une façon individuelle et
moi moi j'ai rencontré plein de
journalistes avec depuis le début de la
promo du film est systématiquement ce
qui revient moi je suis pas quelqu'un de
banlieue mais mais c'est une culture que
je connais pas ce que je pense que j'ai
vécu à travers ça mais parce que vous
avez des amis mais ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que tout le monde dit
alors comment ça se passe en banlieue
c'est jacques chaque ville ait sa
banlieue ils ont chaque chaque banlieue
à des cités
chaque site et à des habitants et chaque
habitant fonctionne d'une façon
différente est complètement autonome
donc nous ça c'est que c'est une réalité
personne qu'on me dit rien on est assez
existait pas il ya un rebeu qui
fonctionne comme ça mais mais c'est pas
la reine était à tous les rôles au
fonctionnement du jazz au likès vous
pensé du film
moi je pense qu'un film je trouve assez
modeste sûr que ce crime se fera
beaucoup de bruit parce qu'il prend
vraiment aux tripes il parle de choses
crûment de manière parfois un peu
violente parfois excessive mais je crois
que ça correspond aussi à certaines
réalités
tout à l'heure ils disaient que
chaque banlieue à ses habitants ce jeune
cette érection différent bien sûr mais
on retrouve aussi pas mal de choses
communes dans les quartiers nous montre
avec mon équipe dans toutes les villes
de france la région parisienne marseille
lille roubaix tourcoing la région
lyonnaise et autres on trouve quand même
des choses compliquées qui se transforme
des modes de comportements des modes
vestimentaires les manières de manière
dire ce sont de caractériser des restos
pu faire un mélange à la fois de
génération mélange d'ethnies un mélange
de langues à mélange aussi de
d'habitudes alimentaires des frictions
comme ça peut exister un peu de violence
dans les comportements aussi 7
cette incapacité parfois à communiquer
avec d'autres notamment il ya une scène
où il arrive dans une main dans une
exposition de peinture où on voit bien
qu'il ya là ils veulent draguer mais ils
n'arrivent pas toujours à draguer comme
il faut donc il ya une sorte de violence
dans le comportement qui corresponde à
une réalité je crois que ce film au delà
de l'aspect parfois un peu de qui peut
choquer certaines bonnes âmes traces
comme une réalité qui est qui est tout à
fait vrai mais correspond les choque
c'est que c'est pas des bonnes âmes non
moi je crois que c'est important aussi
que des gens qui travaillent dans ces
quartiers et qu'ils s'y intéressent
puisse voir ce type de finition aussi
nation parce qu'il ya des gens oui parce
qu'il ya des gens qui savent les
quartiers de banlieue
moi je ne crois pas que c'est un film
qui vraiment provoque la haine que c'est
un film qui ouvre les yeux qui est
d'essayer des yeux c'est pas un film
anti flics je ne crois pas qu'il le soit
qu'il faut comprendre comme ça y est
quel est votre sentiment
je pense que c'est exactement ce que
vient de dire mathieu kassovitz jeu
contente d'ailleurs d'avoir la
confirmation de ce que j'ai ressenti ses
excès c'est une part de réalité c'est
pas toute la réalité lui s'est attaché à
la violence extrême et il a voulu
vraiment accentuer son film sur les
bavures policières les relations les
rations le manque de dialogue
l'impossible dialogue entre la police
les jeunes donc c'est une forme de
violence
elle est spectaculaire no dans le
documentaire on ne sait absolument pas
attaché à ça partant du principe est
donc on sort complètement de la fiction
que les médias les actualités les
reportages traitait en général
effectivement des bavures et jamais du
quotidien non je crois qu'on s'est
attaqué avec erik orsenna à l'initiative
de la fondation de martine aubry sur la
violence quotidienne et c'était ça qu'on
vit dans ce quotidien de la vie des
habitants
donc on est venu sans une idée puisque
c'est pas une fiction sans aucune idée
préconçue sans a priori
dans le scénario vous faut vous avez un
côté des gens qui luttent justement pour
qu'il ne se passe pas des choses telles
qu'on les voit dans le film
nous on a voulu rendre compte de
l'exclusion et de la vie dans les cités
et dans les cités je vais dire comme lui
dans une cité parce que là vous avez un
peu une expression tout à l'heure je
n'ai même pas bien retenu parce que à
marseille ils disent tenir le mur quand
justement on passe sa journée à ne rien
faire c'était que c'était quoi
l'expression est là-bas bon c'est de
tenir le bureau tient le mur toute la
journée
donc c'est vrai évidemment qu'il ya des
points communs c'est sûr vers le chômage
le rien à faire aucune perspective
bon on le retrouve les ya pas de bande à
marseille vous vous situez vraiment on
sent les banques dans votre film pensé
les choses différentes
non non non c'est benjamin s'est pas
désuni mais ça fait dire non mais oui
mais oui oui je suis pas bon
ban de 10 heures jeudi copains aucune
augmentation il ya aucun gant 5
là on a filmé tout le monde connaît tout
le monde tout le temps
c'est très différent j'aurai votre
sentiment déjà par rapport à ce que
disait mathieu s'est au niveau des
prises de conscience déjà c'est vrai
comment le bon moi je lis le film ça va
aller ça m'a fait un froid quand même
mais
bon ça va ça va peut-être de provoquer
quelques déclic chez certains mais une
prise de conscience générale ça
m'étonnerait beaucoup c'est un peu
utopique d'espérer ça ensuite bon déjà
le fait que les gens disent bon alors
comment ça se passe en banlieue
bon alors comment ça se passe au tibet
on a l'impression qu'il ya des milliers
de kilomètres non c'est donc déjà ces
gens n'y vont pas donc ça c'est clair
ces médias se soucie même pas de ce qui
se passe là-bas donc automatiquement les
gens qui vivent là-bas automatiquement
ils se sentent exclus
mise à l'écart bon y'a rien à faire on
va pas y revenir le chômage de et puis
tous les jours quand même par rapport à
ce qu'on en sait de 24 heures de vie de
six mois par exemple il ya quand même
beau la haine ça vient pas c'est pas non
plus la nature la haine mais ça c'est
valable des deux côtés parce que bon il
ya quand même il ya quand même des
petites choses qu'on subit chaque jour
qui vont du tout rien qui vont du qui
vendus
nous allons au bar-tabac vous allez
acheter des cigarettes dont la dame de
bambou s'aperçoit vous êtes derrière
fezensac devant ça va
à peine chose ça va avant tout à l'heure
on est arrivé je mets pas en doute du
tout la la la la même oui à manger un
contrôle d'identité c'est pas le
problème on m'a demandé ma car il nous a
demandé notre qualité pour monter c'est
la phrase d'après ces nous excuser mais
vu la situation il y a bon dos mais ce
soir c'était une mission sur les
banlieues dont je crains
et tout ça ça fait non mais on en rit
mais bon je vais casser vécu au
quotidien on attend des cumuls
régulièrement aux dix par jour comme ça
en moyenne pendant six mois il ya tiens
t'es un minimum légal c'est quelque
chose qu'on a vraiment retrouvé aussi à
marseille c'est cette peur de
l'extérieur tellement l'extérieur vous
repousse et ça c'est vraiment fort quoi
cette notion de planète à part et ils le
disent d'ailleurs si vous vous souvenez
c'est en dehors de la mare schiste et
aux fonds en dehors de tout et on voit
quand la planète vient jusqu'à france 2
tout d'un coup que la planète fait un
peu peur c'est ça je vais vous le dire
oui
philip tagg liga votre sentiment il
faudra dire que je suis passé tranquille
au portillon de sécurité
et pourtant j'avais pourtant j'avais une
bombe lacrymogène dans la poche quoi
donc qu'en ce qui concerne le film de
mathieu kassovitz
je pense que c'est un film juste et
honnête si on la jeunesse la prison
platret du béton est pour moi le plus
important c'est qu'il n'a pas trahi qui
sais pas raconter et je pense pas que ça
soit un film si violent que ça puisque
moi je suis retrouvé un peu plus ou
moins l'ambiance dans laquelle je vis et
je le dis j'ai beaucoup ri en voyant ce
film s'offre à la fin de ces normes on
s'est vraiment mortel qu on va demander
là haut je ne vous vous levez vous
présenter on vous dit de quelle ville
vous êtes donc à qui mme st-louis de
goussainville
vous savez lui c'est sa banlieue
parisienne je le dis pour les val d'oise
j'ai vu le film
mathieu 15 août 15 witch je crois que
c'est une fiction c'est une fiction et
puis on a trop tendance à coller des
différentes réalités qui a dans les
banlieues à des fictions
c'est une fiction il a pris la prive 24
heures il a fait du talent bon après ça
s'excuse pour ce beau certes mais où ça
m'inquiète c'est que je crois qu'un
grand fantasme sur ces fameux quartier
un grand fantasme on entend tout à
l'heure des maladresses depuis tout à
l'heure quelques maladresses en parlant
de bandes ses trois amis qui marche qui
vivent effectivement ils ont vécu une
bavure
ils s'en vont à paris
et ils vivent leur galère si on peut
dire entre guillemets c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas des bandes c'est pas c'est
pas d'aider des théories c'est pas donc
je crois qu'à un moment donné il faut
arrêter
il faut il faut rester sur terre c'est
un film une fiction c'est pas un
reportage restons dans la fiction bien
rythme de dire 'est-ce que vous
identifier à ce film moi quand je vois
un film à la campagne ou deux films ne
demande pas moins une pause autres de
s'identifier
pourquoi quand on quand on content quand
on a un film sur les banlieues
automatiquement on demande une certaine
identification est ce que tu te
reconnaissent que tu te reconnais pas
comment comme j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure je crois que les gens sont
complètement différent avec des cultures
différentes et c'est tout il faut
arrêter de fantasmer sur cinq quartiers
là c'est d'être tous les pass est belle
oui bonsoir je m'appelle kader chibane
je suis de goussainville
la difficulté c'est qu'on est dans le
genre et le cinéma et à qui me l'a bien
dit et la banlieue sur le film de
mathieu kassovitz
je crois qu'on retrouve en bonne partie
la culture banlieue obsession que j'ai
des choses à l'heure il ya une culture
banlieue un deal parler de l'aspect
vestimentaire le bagout et à une culture
banlieue on va à marseille on va dans la
banlieue de paris dans la banlieue on
retrouve des gens qui se ressemblent et
qu'on intérieurement qui sont différents
je crois que sur le film il tombe dans
un contexte est pour ça qu on vous
renvoie des choses c'est pour ça que
malgré tout on vous dit toujours pas
s'il ya un contexte qui est fort ce sera
un film américain on sortirait du film
on irait très bien et moi je remets pas
en cause
l'imaginaire du cinéaste si vous voulez
mais ça tombe dans un contexte et malgré
lui
ce film est pris dans un contexte avec
un certain nombre de documentaires
d'événements sur le film lui-même donc
petite critique comme ça sympathique
mais peut-être deux choses comme ça qui
me dérange
tu parles est purement cinéma peut-être
qu'on ne voit pas assez la cité en toile
de fond je je ne retrouve pas comme
beaucoup de sites et des lieux de
rendez-vous des lotos monde se voit on
la voit peu la cité où c'est peut-être
un parti pris
la première chose est sûre la deuxième à
ce qui me dérange un petit peu c'est moi
tous les films que j'aime habituellement
il ya la transformation d'une
transformation des adultes partent d'un
départ c'est des copains et puis des
choses se passent et il se transforme
on arrive à la fin et j'ai pas
l'impression peut-être que je me trompe
qui est une transformation via des
personnages comme vous le savez vie très
impartial et sur la banlieue pour
terminer je crois que la véritable
difficulté quand il parlait de bande de
trois personnes
je crois qu'on n'arrive pas à
individualiser les relations je veux
dire par là que quand je me déplace à
paris je ne porte pas la banlieue dans
mon sac à dos et on a cette impression
là parce que la forme soit votre tête
sur ma tête oui
non je porte dans mon coeur entre autres
ce serait assez les sentiments qui joue
c'est difficile explique énorme il
termine je termine et il me semble qu'il
faut individualiser les relations parce
que on a trop tendance à juger
l'aspect physique que ce qui peut se
trouver à l'intérieur des individus
passé là depuis qu'à celui de répondre à
tout le monde
je me présente avec un repas michael
suis enseignant puis je viens de vous sa
ville aussi donc j'ai vu le film
et puisque je regrette un petit peu
comme c'est ce sont les premiers films
sur la banlieue
c'est la dimension inhumaines des
personnages c'est assez cru j'ai pas de
repères je vois personne à aller à
l'école
je vois pas parler d'amour donc c'est ce
qui c'est ce qui me choque un petit peu
et puis on a tendance que laborieux de
sem alcaniz un petit peu je veux que je
vois des jeunes qui sont qui sont entre
eux j'étais sur le toit j'avais jamais
vu ça à faire des merguez tout ça
personnellement c'était choquant point
s'imagine un mot je conteste pas ça peut
exister c'est réel donc c'est une
victime ce qui me fait un peu peur donc
ce comme c'est ce sont des nouveaux
films la banlieue on la renforce
on renforce les clichés sur les
immortalise donc je m'adresse un petit
peu en face me reste à la france
profonde
déjà ça ça se vit mal d'être ennuyeux
pour les gens donc on fantasme
qu'est ce qui se passe comme si c'était
une autre planète réellement on nous dit
toujours en ville et de banlieue comme
si on est extraordinaire on mange pas
comme tout le monde les différents coûts
c'est ça qui fait un peu peur mais sinon
on va pas contester le talent ou quoi
que ce soit c'est un film c'est vrai que
ça peut exister voilà ce qu'on peut la
sauver
oui non c'est ça le seul truc qu'il faut
se dire et c'est vrai que il ya une
question que vous me posez c'est est ce
qu'il faut et ce qu'il faut pas faire ce
genre de film ça c'est ça c'est une
vraie je pense est une vraie question
après ça me fait plaisir de que vous
voulez y ai pas vu que c'est que c'est
un truc que vous ayez pas vu vos yeux
des trucs sur les merguez sur le toit
personnellement j'ai pas vu non plus
mais je sais que ça existe c'est des
trucs qui existe j'ai vu j'ai vu la même
chose sous un truc différent mais bon là
on l'a mis là dessus parce que c'est mal
graphiquement c'est critique c'est sur
le manque d'amour il dit j'ai pas vu
l'amour j'ai pas pu passer le temps
parce que j'ai juste juste par rapport à
ça et par rapport aux autres sur le ne
pas avoir assez de banlieue sa mêlée ça
met les pendules pour moi ça me ramène à
mettre les pendules à l'heure c'est que
c'est pas un film pour moi sur les
banlieues c'est un film sur les bavures
policières
c'est un film sur le système des bavures
policières le problème des bavures
policières c'est que c'est des trucs qui
sont en rapport direct avec le racisme
le racisme ça tombe sur qui ça tombe sur
les arabes ça tombe sur les noirs les
noirs et les arabes où on les retrouve
le plus malheureusement c'est un non
lieu dans les cités
donc forcément on est obligé de faire de
mettre l'action aussi pour des raisons
que ça fait partie des premiers films
qui parlent de ça et que malheureusement
on est obligés de situer sa là dessus de
la barre s'il y avait eu plus de deux
médias avant le film qui avait parlé de
ce sujet on a peut-être ce serait être
attaqué ou mêlant policière une façon
plus enfin une station différente en
tout cas là aujourd'hui les mettant dans
le 16e arrondissement
non mais par exemple aujourd'hui moi
j'habite à belleville dans les quartiers
il ya eu 250 personnes qui sont révoltés
parce qu'il ya un mec qui s'est fait qui
s'est fait arrêter pour des mauvaises
raisons bon là on est et on est allé
bouffer juste à côté on est dans le 8e
arrondissement ici il y avait des mecs
qui ont marqué des voitures sur les
champs-elysées il ya eu bagarre avec un
avec un flic qui a tapé sur un mec parce
que plein milieu de champs elysées donc
les bavures sous toutes ses formes que
ce soit d'une gifle ou d'une balle ça
arrive partout c'est pas un truc de
sites et c'est pour ça que je n'ai pas
que ce soit à 100% cité est-ce qu'on
peut passer le micro à au jeune fille
est ce qu'elle est ce que vous n'avez
pas été frappé de voir qu'on ne voit pas
de
deux femmes deux filles de jeunes filles
dans ce film les meubles et bibelots
s'il vous plaît mais vous n avez pas
vous devez pas parler dans le micro s'il
vous plaît vous avez pas apporté ce
sujet sur les filles seraient les meufs
sur les nanas je sais pas moi comme vous
voulez ça c'est le même problème que
tout le reste c'est qu'on prend une
heure et demie d'un film ça dure une
heure et demie ça dure pas ça peut pas
durer 20 heures mais c'est dur et 20h on
pourrait pas tout mettre dans donc il ya
des choses qu'on est obligés d'éviter
qu'on est obligé de on est obligé de
survoler les relations on voit les
relations elles sont les survols dans le
film avec le ratio entre saïd et sa
soeur mais il ya un truc c'est que c'est
que d'une façon normale et ça c'est un
truc qui épiait dans toutes les cités
par exemple c'est que les filles ne vous
traîne pas avec les mecs pour une raison
très simple c'est que c'est les soeurs
des frères donc en plus des filles comme
ça présente dans ce film parce que les
trois copains on parle en permanence oui
c'est surtout d'ailleurs side il en
parle tout le temps des remparts tout
honneur répondre 3 il sait qu'il n'ya
pas d'amour dans le film on parle pas
tout ça c'est qu'on est partis sur la
base dans le travail dans le sens où on
essaie de faire un espèce de médecine
potes comme ça toutes les émotions qui
peut y avoir là bas et fait que les gens
ils sont perdus les personnels en
banlieue les gens sont perdus
il manque d'amour terriblement c'est des
gens complètement cessé d herbe qui
pousse sauvagement comme ça c'est ma
d'amour en banlieue bien sûr qu a pas
d'amour et c'est une réalité
et puis c'est comme ça et c'est tout non
mais c'est pas qu'il ait pas de mon nom
y avait des relations amicales sont
difficiles à van sant et décide de faire
un film sur les banlieues est et parler
d'histoire d'amour je trouve je pense
que ça pourra venir en deuxième période
c'est que là maintenant on commence à
faire des films sur les banlieues et
c'est bien que ce soit des films sur les
banlieues ce soit que ce soient des
films durs je pense parce que c'est vrai
qu'il faut mettre il faut mettre des
coups de pieds dans l'eau
il faut en mettre plein la gueule aux
gens un certain niveau parce que les
gens ne comprennent pas par rapport aux
journées ce que j'ai entre les gens
venaient des mecs mais l'événement du
jeu
la rédactrice en chef de l'événement de
jeudi qui nous dit mais des trucs mais
tu n'y crois pas quand tu veux me vient
interviewer elle te dis et ce qui
l'intéresse
alors c'est vrai il regarde il regarde
les films vidéos sur des télés trafiqués
et c'est tout ce qui m'intéresse c'est
comment ils ceux qui se procurent les
télés est ce que vous avez fait brûler
deux voitures sur le tournage que les
trucs comme ça quand on voit après le
papier qu'elle a faits qui perd positive
sur le film qu'il bonne critique où la
file dit des trucs on voit des scènes
avec les bandes rivales qui vendent des
merguez sur les toits des concours de
pirouette clandestine pour parler des
séquences de danse c'est les gens qui
n'ont rien de construit essais des
journalistes
j'ai eu des embrouilles avec des
journalistes avec qui j'ai pas voulu
terminer des discussions parce qu'il
était tellement à l'opposé de d'un
minimum de logique sociale mais la base
la base de 20 millions d'humilité et de
compréhension sur ce qui se passe autour
de soi que il faut il faut rentrer dans
le lard c'est à ce niveau là il faut
rentrer dans le lard et faire des
histoires faire faire un film sur la
banlieue et sur une histoire d'amour
je trouve ça aujourd'hui je trouve pas
que ce soit une bonne idée je pense que
plus tard enfin en plus non je viens de
dire une connerie tout tout les gibiers
sont les bonnes mais mais pour moi
personnellement je trouve ça intéressant
maintenant de rentrer dans le lard et
une et d'intelligence excusez moi aussi
des films je trouve c'est que par
rapport à ce qu'ils disent est aussi les
trois c'est que je pense que là c'est
quand je vous répond directement
bien sûr bien sûr ils n'ont pas la même
famille
est ce que je voulais dire c'est que
j'ai même pu en tout cas tu l'as dans le
film il ya un travail tout à fait
remarquable sur le langage sur
l'engagement c'est la même chose c'est
pas un travail il n'y a pas de travail
sur le langage est comme ça il faut une
[ __ ] et c'est comme ça non mais de
penser comme ça une bonne année mais
c'est moi on dit mais comment vous avez
travaillé la démarche les costumes
l'ambiance les trucs là c'est la nature
je sais pas aller c'est hong kong [ __ ]
c'est de l'autre côté du périph quoi
c'est vraiment l'autre côté du périph
vous montre pas tu vas à 500 mètres même
temps c'est pas quand il essaye de me
parler comment vous dit comment tu
parles de masseur toi quand même on vous
dit vous savez il ya des mecs ya des
mecs qui ont fait des bouquins le des
mecs qui ont fait débat sur les
vêtements du jeudi ils ont fait une arme
ils ont faim ils font des lexiques sur
les insultes la mère machin tu avais
envie du lycée arthur qui fait ça ils
sont beaucoup d'argent avec ça laisser
les médecins dans leur bouquin c'est pas
fait pour être maître sur mis sur les
t-shirts s'est pas fait peser tam et à
l'issue des ours n'est pas fait pour
être mais sur des tee shirts etc de
trucs
bah ouais c'est dommage ils ont pu donc
ça existe on est un peu dans le même
sens je crois qu'on a fait on a fait
aujourd'hui moi je rentre dans une
bibliothèque dans une librairie je vois
encore une fois un livre qui s'appelle
ta mère on essaye de voir et encore là
c'est alors ta mère ta mère fait du ski
à je sais pas quoi sert il à faire il
obtient comme issa il a voulu s'exprimer
de mode
il a voulu s'exprimer on lui dit comment
comment vous dites comme si que c'était
un petit marcia quoi je crois qu'à un
moment donné il faut prendre en
considération
1 les gens qui vivent dans ces quartiers
ses y vivent dans un pays c'est un pays
qui est pas diviser en 36 mois et ça
porte préjudice à nous porte préjudice
pour ceux qui vivent comme nous tout à
l'heure on a eu des problèmes pour se
garer et ses résultats on va pas rentrer
dans ces anecdotes à parce qu'on sent on
s'en sort plus mais il faut un moment
donné décoller parce que dépasser
dépasser tout ça parce que quand on voit
et on a eu à faire encore une fois des à
des journalistes qui arrivent et qui
nous prennent mais vraiment comme des
martiens tout à l'heure il parlait du
festival de cannes - le film il est
c'est vrai qu'il est violent
il est violent il ya beaucoup d'humour
ils portent beaucoup d'humour très bien
mais moi il a été violent pour moi ça
veut dire que moi j'habite dans un
quartier jeu
je suis à l'aise dans ce que je vois il
faut un peu dépassé tout ça et puis puis
pas prendre les quartiers comme des
comme des com-zones qu'on visite en
voiture
je crois qu'on m'en donne un beau petit
clin d'oeil avec avec l'espace et la
caméra à l'épaule donc soyons un peu
plus objectif dans ce qu'on dit une
façon générale il ya donc ce qui se
disait qu en fait une des intelligences
du film c'est que là ils m'ont trop il
montre pas la banlieue du doigt en
disant regardez comment ça se passe en
banlieue c'est que tu es de donc
directement
donc tu suis à toi de suite envie de
suivre les gens parlent comme ça on se
déplace comme ça on vit comme ça et ça
après c'est aux spectateurs de suivre et
je trouve que c'est plus intelligent que
de dire voilà comment ça se passe en
montrant du doigt comme justement comme
si on était aux autres excuses à un
autre on dernier sou parce que quand
même ils viennent de goussainville et à
goussainville ont fait ils ont fait le
fil numériques chibane hexagone et -
hexagoal j'ai vu pendant que j'étais en
train on était en préparation métis on a
dit je vous ai même été voir ensemble
parce que c'est des films qui ont été
fait à l'arraché
si je t'ai fait sans une caillasse et
qui sont même chose même la même chose
que pour la haine qui sont discutables
niveau 2 du cinéma ou de quoi que ce
soit mais au niveau de la réalité du
marché de quartier c'est vrai et ça
c'est important malheureusement c'est
des films cd films ça ça devrait
ça devrait être vu par des millions de
personnes c'était important que mercy de
berkman de tarkovski séparé
et alors et c'est vide bailly à vous
vous dans le partage qu'on a vu on va
avoir un petit extrait là dans une
seconde s'est extrait c'est vous savez
vous montrer c'est au contraire l'entrée
de la générosité
je dirai pas ce qu'est la vaillance la
patience des gens vous avez rencontré
dans le quartier nord de marseille nous
surtout ce qu'on a voulu montrer c'est
la diversité des situations des
personnalités des gens qui habitent est
effectivement un des points communs
c'est la manière dont ils se battent et
l entraide parce que c'est vraiment
énorme solidarité qu'on a rencontrés et
on le voit à tous les âges
et c'est ce qu'on a voulu montrer dans
le film est justement ne pas partir sur
une histoire un personnage et le suivre
parce que ça serait trop réducteur sur
le témoignage de deux assistantes
sociales je crois que vous avez donc
rencontrer et qu'on a pu voir dans jour
ordinaire dans la cité la cité est une
planète
personne ne la quitte personne n'y hand
sauf des spécialistes de l'entraînement
explorateurs ni humanitaire un beau jour
débarquèrent sur cette planète
marie noëlle et valérie assistante
sociale de leur état
comme tout le monde elle se retrouve au
niagara le seul lieu convivial du
quartier
[Musique]
j'ai découvert le le quartier en entrant
à l'école et
ça a été le choc j'ai bien peu peur ça
ne correspond à ce que j'ai pu entendre
au sujet du quartier en environnement
personnel puisque j'habite les quartiers
sud et que par opposition quartiers nord
l'a46 sud
ces paradis et les quartiers nord c'est
l'enfer mais
vraiment non j'ai dit c'est pas possible
chez trois années dans ces quartiers
j'ai pas tenir
j'ai pensé tout ça parce que je l'aimé
tellement peur qu'on me vole ma voiture
labine qu'on m'agresse personnellement
qu'on essaye de marcher mes vêtements
parce que ils correspondaient pas au
look on doit avant dans ce quartier
enfin bon bref auraient l'idée de donner
un gramophone
après avoir été choqué c'est à dire
complètement interloquée bout d'une
semaine où j'étais là en circulant dans
le dans le quartier en circulant dans la
cité en s'approchant des gens ton regard
change c'est à dire que c'est plus des
choses inconnues c'est plus des
personnes comme ça que tu vois de loin
qui mon dieu est-ce qu'ils vont se
casser la gueule
est-ce qu'ils vont être agressif envers
moi parce que c'est c'est des choses qui
circulent ces deux idées qui circulent
au niveau des médias
oui alors bon pendant que passé ce livre
j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone de vice
président d'une société anti drogue et
qui protestent contre votre casquette
qui parce qu'elle représente
féler cannabis une feuille de cannabis
bon alors vous la gardez l'enlever
sommes en fait je la garde parce que je
vois pas ce que je vois pas je pense que
ça va le foot là bon et alors voilà donc
des personnages comme ça comme ces deux
on en trouve beaucoup en banlieue d'un
trek ce qui est significatif c'est que
c'est ce que dit eric dans son corps
commentaire c'est qu'effectivement ce
qui rentre dans les cités en tout cas
dans les quartiers nord parce que encore
une fois nous avons écrit que dans les
quartiers nord c'est toutes les
associations c'est les travailleurs
sociaux et c'est pas une entreprise se
sont pas des acteurs économiques alors
adil jalloul il alla vous présentez pas
de ramage de dire assez complet tous ces
associations le qui sont québec qui sont
dans les banlieues qui se font de
l'entr'aide et qui celui qui milite etc
alors vous avez créé banlieue skopies en
deux mots c'est quoi banlieue skopies
c'est un programme
2 d'évaluation des politiques publiques
dans les banlieues ça fait quatre ans
que ça existe donc notre travail
consiste à travailler sur toutes les
villes de france et de navarre el khatib
oculaires qui ont des problèmes et pour
lesquels nous essayons d'amener ça donne
la phase de réflexion et d'analysé de
propositions il se met à frapper dans
tous et combien ne s'est pas une
quinzaine une vingtaine cet indice est
c'est très soupe à tous mais très
souvent il y à une bavure policière
il y à des émeutes et puis bon après il
ya un temps de réflexion et là on voit
se dégager des jeunes souvent qu'une
grande personnalité et qui vont créer
qui vont faire quelque chose pour créer
des associations et parce que je vois
est à l'image du film
ces quartiers populaires sont capables
du pire et du meilleur le pire bien sûr
c'est mais le pire aussi par réaction
face à loeb a je dirais à plein de
choses plein de petites frustrations de
petites brimades quotidiennes
à un moment donné une bavure policière
un crime à caractère sécuritaire aux
racistes la provoc c'est un peu la jirs
est la goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le
vase
nous avons des émeutes alors bien sûr on
brûle ce commercial parfois la tête
comme ça est police ou attaquent la
mairie mais en même temps au-delà de ces
deux trois jours d'émeutes où aussi il
faut le dire
pour la première fois parfois certains
jeunes renverse le rapport de force par
rapport aux forces de police
parce qu'individuellement ils ont
toujours tort nous en tant que contre la
police collectivement parfois ils
peuvent l'espace d'une émeute renverser
le rapport de force et à barbe raison
contre les forces de l'ordre et s'est
pas non plus inintéressant parce que
trois ans après quatre ans après il on
parle encore de ces émeutes là c'est des
moments d'émotion intense mais quelques
semaines quelques mois après nous avons
nous voyons émerger des gens qui disent
bon ben là très bien il ya des bavures
ces émeutes
malgré ce qu'on fait on construit quoi
est ce qu'il ya un crs qui est important
c'est ce que des gens du quartier
des jeunes des moins jeunes ben créé des
structures associatives créé des
entreprises d'insertion qu'elle est
chaude pour dire 'nous ne l'a pas
attendu pouvoirs publics
ça a pas tomber de leur du ciel ben nous
on est capable de faire des choses de
faire bien aussi par nous-mêmes totaux à
sartrouville vous dites je suis
l'incarnent l'éducateur de la rue
d'aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui la toto par
rapport aux autres
ben tout simplement c'est quelqu'un qui
est présent parce que malheureusement on
a pris pas des éducateurs
travers sociaux ils ont un métier et
travaillent huit heures par jour comme
tout le monde et donc ils rentrent chez
eux le soir
toto ses animateurs gérer un nouveau
type c'est un gars de la cité
il a fait une formation mais lui les
présents 14 heures 16 heures par jour en
pied de tours donc là j'ai alors s'il ya
un problème et ça me va pouvoir le
trouver
donc c'est quelqu'un qui est proche il
comprend les situations qui peut amener
assez rapidement des solutions des
combines aussi puissant et puis s'en
sortir et de toto il a plein dans ces
quartiers alors les associations
effectivement ce qui est ce qui est
assez intéressant vote il sait que vous
montrer la diversité de ces associations
alors d'abord ils ont des noms tout à
fait étonnante par exemple que c'est mon
vendredi si elles m'ont vendredi à
nanterre mais bon c'est évidemment
l'émission de chavannes il ya les
craignos à lille il ya dans la rue la
danse à roubaix etc
j'ai espoir la boîte à idées neuves à
nîmes donc il ya les noms d'abord les
noms très souvent correspond aussi à une
sorte de dire et de plaisanterie quand
il me donnait de l'humour aussi parce
que dans ces quartiers je voulais sur
ceux qui ne connaissent pas ces quatre
populaire on rit beaucoup beaucoup plus
d'un quartier bourgeois beaucoup plus
parce que il ya aussi
non parce que il ya de la misère et des
problèmes mais aussi la solidarité de
chaleur humaine il ya aussi du rire
c'est une tradition populaire le rire
c'est pas traditions bourgeoises dans
ces quartiers il ya beaucoup de rires il
ya beaucoup d'émotions même dans les
noms dans les noms de dans l'association
il ya aussi de l'humour est ce qui est
intéressant c'est vraiment une diversité
à la fois deux générations nous avons un
pierrefitte des parents africains qui
s'organise nous avons à nanterre des
jeunes filles s'organise nous avons à
roubaix de jeunes vraiment adolescents
qui font de la danse
donc il ya une très grande diversité les
situations sont malheureusement commune
mais la réaction des habitants qu'ils
soient jeunes ou moins jeunes est très
diverse pour essayer de créer de lien
social et autre chose joe et ça y est
vous êtes d'accord sur cette qualité
d'humour on trouve dans les banlieues ah
oui tout à fait on passe la journée à
rigoler c'est pour ça que bon
dans le film c'est comme ça donc
mais en fait dans le film ce qui s'est
exactement pareil j'en avais le film
j'étais mort de rire tout le long à ce
point là jusqu'à la fin mais mort de
rire quand même parce que non tout
d'abord par rapport à celui auquel les
trois indices à bondy au nord de kehl
les 3 c'est une fiction mais en même
temps quand même quand j'ai regardé le
film quand même il ya des scènes quand
même qui me rappeler certaines choses
qui étaient quand même pas tirer
totalement des imaginaires comme tu vois
il a agi qu'il faut il faut il faut
quand même faut quand même dire que bon
vis-à-vis des jeunes aux comportements
des de la police est pas toujours
ils disent pas toujours vous non mais
c'est à paris safari cativen après
j'avais déjà mais en plus bon c'est
partout la même c'est pareil dans tous
les quartiers on passe son temps se
vanner entre nous obasohan a rigolé avec
ce qu'on a
et malheureusement il ya des moments
qu'on passe bien il ya peu il ya des
moments du film qui sont très proches de
la réalité aussi et qui sont pas
forcément agréables comme par exemple
quand vous garde à vue dans le
commissariat
bon ça c'est pas de la fiction il faut
quand il faut quand même plus un chat
c'est pas la fiction
moi j'ai passé une nuit attaché à un
radiateur allumé avec les menottes à me
faire c'était pas de la fiction je vous
prie de croire donc bon il ya quand même
des choses qui sont même si l'humour de
la même façon que l'humour qu'on
retrouve dans le film c'est le même dans
la réalité mais de la même façon et à
certains cinq autres dans les films qui
sont les mêmes dans la réalité et ça
faut pas l'oublier comme s'est passé
passait pas que du fictif ce qui
apparaît aussi quand même dans votre
livre c'est en gros même si l'image est
très forte
l'expression travaux c'est la démission
des parents est d'ailleurs tahar
benjelloun qu'est le président je crois
de mai dans son avant propos
il dit que les pères ne sont plus des
exemples pour les enfants c'est pas la
démission c'est plutôt la fatigue de la
famille des parents parce qu'on le sait
bien c'est pas la même chose
nous on parle pas de démission pam on
dit que ses parents ont été licenciés de
la vie c'est pas la même chose
les parents dans ces quartiers n'ont pas
démissionné par rapport à leur rôle
seulement ils ont très souvent des
grandes familles ils ont des enfants qui
pose malheureusement plus de problèmes
qu'ailleurs ils ont aujourd'hui
problèmes que rencontrent beaucoup de
parents à savoir du mal à faire croire
aux enfants que l'école est une promesse
qu'il faut que j'aille à l'école parce
que avec un diplôme peut voir un travail
parce que malheureusement aujourd'hui on
sait très bien que même avec un diplôme
il est assez difficile de trouver un
travail
donc les codes n'est plus un lieu où on
va on même en espérant je dirais mais
aussi un petit peu on espère qu'un jour
on aura un diplôme et un travail non
donc ils ont du mal à tenir leurs gosses
et parfois il se laisse un peu aller à
je dirais à la fatigue ils baissent les
bras
c'est le retard benjelloun d'une chose
que je trouve très important a dit le
père n'est plus un modèle et parce que
le père a été cassée été cassé par
l'usiné parce qu'ils demandent aussi le
chômage de longue durée parfois parce
que elle était licenciée parce qu'ils
sont inutiles parfois lorsque dans la
région parisienne
les grandes entreprises 10 ans et par
milliers les salariés à 45 50 ans
aujourd'hui un ouvrier licencié 45 qu'on
sait pertinemment qu'il est grillé
jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
comment voulez vous qu'un enfant qui a
10 ans qu'il ya 15 ans puis ça va comme
exemple un père qui traînent toute la
journée qui n'a pas je dirais un travail
qui n'a pas une une vie dirait ordinaire
donc il a du mal à swan autorités d'où
effectivement le fait que des gamins
n'arrive à prendre leurs pairs comme
exemples et des fois les pas
effectivement ils deviennent silencieux
et se taisent de plus en plus oui on
jette aussi skate et leur père parce que
sa chair dans libé - quand on a fait
émerger de faire le normal par un enfant
non mais par rapport au 2e tour par
rapport aux métiers et aux modèles g que
sur différentes scènes courtes séquences
qu'on a tourné sur le soutien scolaire
quand on leur dit pourquoi on fait du
soutien scolaire parce qu'on veut faire
destituer parce qu'on veut avoir un
métier qui soit différent de celui de
notre père oui oui il fut nommé gers est
aussi quelque chose qui la notion de
référence de modèles et de repères elle
est distendu
vous parlez de pierrefitte lilia
scène étonnante là une réunion de
parents où l'on voit bien que
l'éducation bayonne des africains je
crois qu'ils sont nombreux à pierrefitte
et puis l'éducation évidemment tel qu'on
l'a on la dispense en français il ya une
sorte de d'opposition et pas création il
ya tout simplement des différences dire
on a les références culturelles des
parents africains récemment arrivé à peu
près de dix ans en france qui
s'aperçoivent au bout de quelques
quelques temps que leurs enfants
ben font des bêtises le soir alors bon
ils s'organisent entre eux pour dire
qu'est ce qu'on fait ben ils font des
rondes le soir à 6h à 8h à 10h à minuit
bishop les gamelles et abbas quand ils
font des conneries ça ne marche pas très
bien parce que l'école dit nantes on est
donc maintenant parce que quelqu'un les
enfants vous disent elles à l'école que
mon père me tabasser de l'enseignant
proteste proteste l'assistante sociale
ces prothèses
les parents ont dit mais qu'est ce qu'on
fait lorsque on tapait gamins pour
mettre un peu dans la ligne droite on se
fait attaquer par les socialo qui est
imprenable dirait de décliner votre
système d'éducation normatif français un
système d'éducation africains qui et ses
traditions et ses propres valeurs
tout le travail de cette association
qu'ils ont créée à perrefitte c'est de
rapprocher
il invitait de l'est les professeurs
d'école vous inviter le principal du
collège
il invitait directeur d'école primaire
pour approcher le modèle éducatif pour
voir comment est-ce qu'on peut entre
parents et éducateurs et enseignants
rapprocher les points de vue ça ce que
l'on fait c'est pas de quoi qu'il a fait
cette démarche là ce sont les parents
qui sont allés voir le
je dirais aux enseignants moi je ne suis
pas d'accord avec toi dit l'homme à la
djellaba c'est une réunion à pierrefitte
on est en france citadine gosse comme
comme lui tu peux pas les éduquer en
france ils ont un seul enfant
moi j'ai dix enfants moi je tape mes
enfants jusqu'à la mort c'est la seule
manière d éduquer c'est ça le débat au
sein d'associations parce que ce qui est
intéressant c'est que tout ça se dit
publiquement moi franchement je crois
que ce type d'association et si dit des
choses qui se disent par ailleurs
notamment on parle de choses mais ça
c'est important
les familles n'arrivent pas à gérer des
problèmes dans la sphère du privé donc
ils n'ont pas dans la sphère publique
les familles je dirais moyennes
françaises ont du mal à parler de leurs
problèmes ils vont chez le psychologue
mais par exemple que les enseignants ou
qu'ils n'ont pas le beau rôle dans votre
livre
alors que vraiment ils sont vraiment
très méritant qu'on attendait ils n'ont
pas le beau rôle
on parle d'une situation qui est réel
les enseignants font un travail
formidable
oui sans nous le rendons hommage aussi
donc dans la rue la danse et des
enseignants qui ont été déjà de faire
leur travail même temps c'est vrai que
les enseignants les enfants disent des
choses qui sont très durs très très dur
très dur et en même temps il ya une
chose qui m'a alors qu'il m'a vraiment
frappé c'est ceci les profs se trouve
classée aujourd'hui en prof sympa ou pas
sympa alors qu'il ya quelques années il
était classé en bon prof on m'avait prof
parce que justement aujourd'hui je crois
qu'on n'a pas compris assez
les jeunes générations sont attentives
aux comportements des professeurs et des
grands en général
si les grands les respecte ils peuvent
le respecter c'est les gros ne le
respecte pas il ne le respecte pas et
peu importe le contenu de l'enseignement
que donne le professeur ce qui importe
d'abord c'est son attitude et son
comportement à l'égard des gamins et
malheureusement aujourd'hui encore pas
mal d'adultes professeurs aux autres ont
du mal à respecter les enfants alors que
les enfants d'aujourd'hui sont très
souvent précoce et ont envie qu'on la
respecte pas ce qu'ils sont et 10 aux
professeurs et d'adultes d'écouté nous
sommes une personne à part entière et
vous n'avez pas nous parler comme ça
comme des petits nous sommes aussi
capable de réflexion ne pouvant s'y être
ya des choses comme la commune
ressentant mail intégré souvenant
parlait quasiment pas parce que je vois
que c'est un faux problème
sincèrement il y a en france des
musulmans il y à des jeunes musulmans et
des biens musulmans il ya une
revendication musulmane qui me paraît
tout à fait naturel on république laïque
qui respecte bien sûr les pratiques
religieuses
il y est épiphénomène intégristes qui
existe une affaire de police je ne crois
pas moins aux fantasmes je dirai pas ce
que je ne crois pas parce qu'on n'a pas
observé
je vous la sueur sur le terrain on y est
que mon équipe en permanence donc si
franchement il ya des débordements
intégristes grave
franchement on les avait bien repéré
donc il ya quelques épiphénomènes
intégristes mais c'est largement
minoritaire par contre il y en a
effectivement sinon d'associations
musulmanes qui existent elles ont le
droit d'exister parce que elle travaille
dans le cadre des lois de la république
donc je vais pas où il ya un problème
s'ils ont effectivement a encore une
fois mettre le doigt sur une population
particulière qui non seulement sont en
situation je dirais de mise à l'écart
mais qui en plus lorsqu'elle demande
directe des lieux de culte se trouve
aussi la mise à l'écart
bernard moreau écrivait l'autre jour
dans son éditorial de françois il
écrivit aussi à françois ne sont chaque
jour des dizaines de lettres que nous ne
publions pas parce que nous n'osons pas
trop dur trop inquiétant ce n'est pas un
courrier de la colère c'est bien pire ne
correspondant crient leur désespoir et
lorraine avec des mots d'injures
griffonné rageusement et qui sont
finalement autant d'appels au secours et
l'immense majorité de ces lettres
viennent de paris de la banlieue donc
leur thème commun la révolte contre les
conditions de câbles orbi soulier
dégradé et c est ce que vous avez lu ces
lettres vous vous les voyez c'est là
bien sûr mais c'est le cas tout le monde
dirait s'il faut quand même bien voir
c'est dans ces quartiers
tout le monde se plaint des problèmes je
dirais d'urbanisme des problèmes
transport des problèmes de santé
d'éducation français émigré ensemble
parce que malheureusement ils subissent
les mêmes situations
donc ça crée aussi bien sûr pas mal de
friction entre des gens et lorsqu'on
n'arrive pas à trouver des responsables
de ces questions là et bien tout va me
qu'émissaire c'est parfois l'arabe
parfois de juifs parfois de noir parfois
d'autres donc je crois qu'il faut aussi
faire attention à ne pas mettre de
l'huile sur le feu sur le feu ces gens
là qui réagissent comme ça qu'ils votent
notamment pour l'extrême droite ont
certainement du malheur qui va exprimer
mais c'est pas ont le courage aussi type
de dix mois des pratiques qu'on va
régler le problème au contraire philip
tagg vous lisez vous avez présenté leur
disant vous êtes à la fois photographe
et poète est ce que pour vous la
photographie et la poésie c'est et
notamment quand vous photographier des
enfants dans la banlieue et que vous
écrivez des textes qui accompagnent ces
photographies est ce que c'est un peu la
même démarche créative
oui je pense que mon jeu france pense
que ça va changer grand chose en
banlieue mais c'est mou donnant aussi en
quoi c'est une goutte d'eau dans l'océan
mais je pense que mon c avec eux avec
les gouttes d'eau corps plein océan même
si c'est un peu naïf mais bon le travail
que j'ai fait si vous voulez c'est un
peu une erreur de parcours
moi j'ai tout le temps écrit sur la
jeunesse la plus ample attrait du béton
c'est à dire ceux à qui on a voulu
supprimer les allocations familiales
pour vous donner une image et un jour
j'ai voulu rajouter comme la
photographie
donc j'ai réquisitionné tous les
appareils volet de la cité et le
problème c'est que quand j'ai été voir
la bande qu'on était avec lattes en
mille morceaux quoi c'est à dire que
certains étaient morts certains certains
étant en prison d'autres continué à
galérer et d'autres à laisser leur vie
tout simplement
donc j'ai dû me rabattre sur la dernière
génération des sur la dernière
génération de la cité c'est à dire les
enfants
8 à 14 ans quoi ceux qui sont encore
protégés par la passe par insouciance de
l'enfance il ya déjà une gravité soin
visage mais aussi le rire aussi il ya eu
il ya une beauté est elle donc tous ces
photos ont été prises à villejuif et de
george iii au cours de l'été 93 donc
c'est dans le quartier mermoz
voilà ma mamma cité oui et donc c est ce
que c'est des enfants vue laisser ses
photographies et comment réagit on
pourrait citer un prix magique puisque
un livre c'est magique
oui donc quand ils sont maintenant c'est
comme si je voyais à la télé quoi ils
comprenaient pas s'étonner vous
accompagner toutes ces photographies de
texte mais avec un léger décalage c'est
josé un décalage politique peut ainsi je
pense pas que ce soit un des cas là je
pense que c'est plutôt une béquille à la
photo le sens inverse au fin fond d'une
cave j'ai rencontré lamartine mermoz et
d'humains qui me demandais pourquoi tant
de galères en leur nom grâce à ces un
poème parce que mon état de jeunes ne
savent pas l'histoire du d'une idée du
personnage dans lequel ils habitent qui
savent l'histoire de la cité si on leur
dit de ci voulant demander de raconter
l'histoire de la cité mermoz à lyon
vouloir ils vont vouloir raconter mais
si vous leur dites c ki moon et des
petits avant que te droguer et cool
l'oiseau chante et c'est le cri de la
liberté
mais alors ça c'est un j'étais dans une
cage d'escalier et j'ai un copain qui
rentre et qui me sort ça donc j'ai
trouvé très beau et vous avez une jolie
phrase aussi mais j'oublie de la notte
sur le sur la neige qui tombe dans la
banlieue quand même la neige devient
deviennent ris quand elle tombe en
banlieue oui et puis ceci tout a
commencé
on voit évidemment de trois jeunes
provenant banlieue tout a commencé quand
les tic comme vous ont négligé les types
comme moi ouais je pense que c'est une
vérité fondamentale
à partir du moment où on a un peu de
pouvoir et qu'on néglige l'autre ont
sacré problème
oui alors je vous avais alors une
compétence s'est passé il ya eu une
musique vous avez fait vous est demandé
des musiques à plusieurs groupes ce qui
s'est passé c'est que il ya quand j'ai
dit tiens comme l'on dit qu'est ce que
tu vas faire après midi sont les
questions à faire je dire je fais un
truc s'appelle la haine sur les bavures
policières à bon ça va être drôle et ça
c'était la première recrue que ça a
c'est allé voir des gags et puis
deuxième chose à mourir et var du rap
alors j'ai dit non parce que parce que
c'est pas forcément la musique qui est
qui est la plus la plus répandue en
banlieue ça dépend des quartiers cités
des quartiers qui ont un groupe de rap
dans leur quartier bien sûr sinon non
donc dans le film et du funk par contre
la seule façon de parler bien de la
banlieue à travers la musique et donc
d'élargir le débat du film qui était
comme je le répète un point de vue
équivalent le bon point de vue forcément
donner des points de vue différents
c'était faire ça à la iame vous avez
vous participé à l'écriture de la
musique
on a fait un morceau en fait on en a qui
peut le retrouver tout ça dans ses chais
de la belle il ya plusieurs groupes
évidemment qu'ils vont mais il ya plein
de groupes de rap français donc déjà
c'est une excellente chose et
nos bonnes on a été contactés on a reçu
donc plusieurs sujets parce qu'en fait
c'était inspiré du film donc rien à voir
avec une bo ou avec donc on a reçu
plusieurs appuis en choix possibles de
sujet on a choisi et je pense que chaque
groupe a fait la même chose c'est pour
ça que bon il ya quand même des les
thèmes divers quand même
alors vrai bon c'est une émission qui a
été très grave n'a pas aidé chez les
verts mais j'aimerais quand même qu'on
termine par une chose amusante parce que
vous savez que dans les guignols de
canal on a vu des jeunes des beurs de la
banlieue alors je vous propose de vous
devez vous me direz si vous avez aimé ça
ou pas on va retrouver une séquence est
paru il ya quelques semaines ou quelques
mois
c'est donc avec jacques toubon donc je
voulais monsieur c'est pour moi je la
regarde
bonjour michel voulait ici à peine tu
regardes une lente un voleur c'est pas
bon sens bonjour farid déjeuner je vous
ai fait venir ici afin de mieux
connaître vos envies et vos besoins
voyez who was stade erreurs moi je pense
qu'au niveau de la liberté d'expression
qu'est-ce qui a tout fout de ma gueule
non je rigole
bref ses intérêts c'est jamel dans la
vie c'est nicky vrai chic monnier c'est
au 1 va manger tant mère tu auras parle
pas de ma mère à la télé vous faire
saucisses aux pingouins fantôme
usurpateurs [ __ ] ya monsieur bouffon
et nous invite tous beaucoup d'emplois
et nous inviter toi tu donne une image
de prématurés ta tête
vacher dans sa couveuse tapant
d'amour-propre ponctuent les ne vois pas
qui tu manipules le bouffon là et tout
pas du tout non je voudrais savoir quel
genre de métier vous branche
docteur docteur comme ça il pourra
mattel que sa soeur et le clip qui l'a
pas vue aussi gelé vue web à moi comme
métier je voudrais faire champion du
monde de basket avec les muses à chicago
tribune vous jouer au basket
maintenant je peux perdre aucun d'une
deuxième nous ont piqué le ballon donc
ça fait du bruit dans la cour à cause de
sa femme elle a le cancer a pour pas
dormir la théorie bien sûr et nico
métier alors pour faire ministre
monsieur bouffon faut faire comment tout
bon je m'appelle tous bande est bien
léger oui où j'ai fait l'ena web au
niveau des études et tout ça et
maintenant je parle au niveau scolarité
haussés appelle tout ça il faut quoi
ap si la juge je ne sais pas je n'ai pas
de ses api ou à l'école
si j'ai fait l'ena crois tu m'étonnes
que sa mère de la france
oui alors c'est bon vous avez tous ri
est ce que il n'ya aucune critique là
dessus normalement ces légumes et féru
des guignols mais faut pas tout prendre
le premier degré simplement c'est comme
tout ça c'est intéressant ça bien sûr
que c'est plein d'humour mais moi quand
je regarde j'adore les guignols mais
quand tu regardes les guignols c'est un
vrai reflet de la société entre des
politiques à trouver que c'est un reflet
delà de la banlieue les alors
tous des michael jordan c'est la fête au
monde c'est exactement ce à quoi s'est
saisie c'est cette image là que beaucoup
de gens ont des jeunes issus des
banlieues des gros mots toutes les 5
minutes du basket du rap des casquettes
à la mer va pas plus loin
oui mais c'est du lourd ouais mais oui
mais quelque part quand même c'est
rabaissant je veux dire bon pour me
disais bon ça va
aman lieu il se passe plein de choses
des bonnes et des mauvaises match dans
son film lui a préféré montrer celle
d'amener loin des les mauvaises qui se
montrent très bon oeil les guignols
montre le côté humoristique de la
panouille les gens par exemple on est
loin des guinéens c'est de l'humour déjà
les pinceaux de nous on est mal barré
non mais en plus c'est pas parce que
effectivement il ya des casquette de
travers à l'excès c'est ça fonctionne
différemment c'est pas fins et s'est
passé c'est pas un boulot quoi c'est pas
on donne pas un pacage banlieue tient là
tiens banlieue c'est ça c'est ça
fonctionne pas bon il a un truc par
contre c'est sa vie assez loin des
guignols mais par contre il ya un truc
au début du film c'est les inconnus on a
repris un sketch et un revenu qui est
fait je sais pas pour vous mais pour moi
les sketches des inconnus et manu tu
descends pourquoi ferme achetée pas
descendre pour moi ferme achetée pas
descendre pour quoi faire
c'est ça on l'a vu tu vois de dix fois
par jour le petit peu qu'ils appellent
pour quoi faire
mais la même phrase et ça c'est des
trucs donc nous on l'a mis dans le film
ça peut représenter la haine sorti
mercredi 31 mai dans toute la france et
puis présentation demain soir donc à
cannes au palais
vous allez vous déguisé en pingouin pour
monter les marches à tous
on va pas se déguiser vous savez le
problème c'est que c'est que à partir du
moment où on accepte de jouer le jeu on
joue ici nous ça nous fait plaisir de
s'habiller comme on va s'habiller bon sa
vie de façon objets dont joue le jour
maintenant la bae et ccc c'est tellement
décalé on termine rapidement
le questionnaire votre mot préféré est
celui de concupiscent et le mob ou
détesté mais c'est le mot est composée
notamment de man 1 et le mot vous
détestez concupiscent je sais je sais
nager l'on veut mais fier ça mais j'ai
pas préparé à sa mort parce qu'à une
question cassette qu'elles voudront
préféré alors que les votes drogue
préférée oui je ne prends pas de drogue
en dépit de votre casquette mais non
mais je ne prends pas de drogue
je prends pas de drogue et les il faut
il faut faire attention aux problèmes de
drogue par rapport aux autres trucs de
cannabis il faut ça c'est pas
d'incitation à fumer c'est c'est plus
symbolique qu'autre chose
les gens qui sont à mon dieu il fume pas
tous d'accord c'est pas tous des voleurs
et puis c'est pas parce qu'on porte une
feuille de cannabis qu'on a drogué ou
comprendre alors pourquoi un peu d'éclat
lui supporte le casque ouais je pense
qu'elle y être mais là en plus c'est
symbolique c'est chose et puis et puis
dans certains pays la le cannabis est
utilisé comme comme thérapeute y est
mais pas comme aux forces comme elecam
qui fume c'est ma tête qui fut moine la
grave alors aux éditions actes sud ont
peu joué jusqu'ici tout va bien c'est le
scénario de la haine avec des
photographies ou laver des flux rapide
de gilles favier et parallèlement la
sortie du filet la maison de la ville
est présente jusqu'ici tout va bien
l'expression des images donc de de
gilles favier du 31 mai au 24 septembre
voilà et puis des we qu'elle voulait
dire un mot saint-vil des quelque chose
qui m'a frappé
y a que quelques personnes qui ont dit
la cité où les quartiers et à mon avis
ça veut pas dire même chose que la
banlieue parce que neuilly c'est la
banlieue paris ont fait pas
différenciation et dans chaque quartier
il n'y a pas les mêmes problèmes et moi
j'habite en banlieue
j'habite dans un quartier à côté d'une
cité et je sais absolument pas ce qui se
passe dans cette cité et dans la cité il
ya du bruit et c'est vivant et à côté
dans les zones pavillonnaires c'est mort
voilà c'est tout ce que voulait dire
ils ont pas alors les cahiers du cinéma
des cahiers du cinéma ont mis les trois
acteurs principaux de la n2 kassovitz en
couverture et on trouve kassovitz lui
même dans une de première avec un
spécial kamanzi c'est un écrivain qui a
du talent aux éditions stock territoires
d'outre-mer a aussi c'est sur la cité
aussi où la banlieue comme vous voudrez
et azouz begag zeta auscitains qu'elle
était beaucoup de talent vous le
connaissez peut-être c'est lui qui avait
fait le gone du chaâba il est dans la
banlieue lyonnaise et voici son nouveau
roman les chiens aussi aux éditions du
seuil si vous voulez vous le demander
voilà une base un la culture hip hop aux
éditions desclée de brouwer et puis je
signale de françois ascher métapolis où
l'avenir des villes aux éditions odile
jacob
je signale d'autre part ces deux
ouvrages et pas pu présenter la semaine
dernière parce que j'en avais pas eu le
temps
alors d abel date et philippe harrouard
alain juppé ou la tentation du pouvoir
aux ischions jean claude lattès taille
et ils ont eu le nez creux cela en
faisant ce graphique d'alain juppé de
ghislaine ottenheimer l'impossible
victoire aux éditions robert laffont et
jacques chirac qui vient de couverture
et ça c'est une enquête aussi sur on a
parlé du livre de jacques attali l'autre
jour voici une enquête de christophe
urbano vix lempire nucléaire éclaté aux
éditions michalon
et enfin une reddition du dictionnaire
des oeuvres politique de chapelets
duhamel et pisier aux éditions aux
presses universitaires de france
et puis métis le premier film de
katowice
le premier film de kassovitz pardon
cassette vidéo
et puis ça ça c'est le film dans lequel
vous jouiez le le principal rôle avec
le saintignan le film de jacques audiard
n'était pas arte vidéo regarde les
hommes tomber
et puis je suis ce sas et le film de
spikly version originale de the right
thing
et puis enfin des cassettes décédé ombre
et lumière le dernier album du groupe
iam
c'est chez delabel pour vous donner vous
l'avez quand même et puis ça c'est paris
sous les bombes de suprême ntm chez epic
etc
bon moi j'ai pu le temps je vous
terminerait simplement en rappant donc
le vote film sort mercredi
et puis vendredi prochain une émission
tout à fait exceptionnel qui sera
enregistrée jérusalem sur le thème de
jérusalem d'ailleurs et qui réunira des
israéliens des palestiniens et un
français appartenant aux trois religions
monothéistes la juive la chrétienne et
la musulmane donc la semaine prochaine
bonsoir à tous
[Musique]